what would you write the politicians who
run the world now so that your words
might have a real impact on that eats I
don't really know what is the the impact
that literature can have on on
politicians and I think it's very
difficult to measure in practical terms
the sequel's of literature in the life
of individuals what I am sure is that
good books good literature have an
influence in the life of the readers
because readers change their sensibility
becomes much more alert I think good
books fuel the imagination the fantasy
the appetites the desires of of people
but you cannot measure in quantitative
terms this influence